everybody knows the Muppets and
everybody loves them but after a few
films then didn't do so great suddenly
the Muppets became really unpopular okay
nobody hated them or anything but they
definitely weren't pulling in all the
numbers once in a while you see him on a
commercial or two but they weren't
really in movies or shows or anything
like that anymore this is why the reboot
movie called The Muppets was such a big
deal not only were they trying to get
people interested again but they threw
as much time and effort into it as
possible we're talking big musical
number celebrities emotional moments new
material mixed with old material
commercials and advertisements
everywhere you went and thankfully it
paid off that not just because it was
really really funny and creative but
because it was brilliantly and brutally
honest about people's acceptance of the
Muppets recently two brothers named
Walter and Gary one of them kind of
obviously adopted are going on a
vacation to Los Angeles one of the
reasons being that Walters biggest dream
is become a muppet but he finds out that
the Muppets studio is about to be closed
and bought up by an evil tycoon Sookie
rushes to get all the Muppets back
together to put on a great big show to
raise money to keep it around the
problem is all the Muppets have gone
their separate ways why well because
nobody cares about the Muppets anymore
yeah they're pretty harsh and hammering
in how not popular they are ba Walter
still believes in them as does Gary well
sort of he really just wants a vacation
with his girlfriend Mary but also wants
to help his brother out and yeah you can
see the obvious problem here will they
be able to put on a show and raise
enough money so that they won't lose the
studio Oh what do you think
no actually doesn't turn out exactly how
you think but in a way it kind of does
but in some ways it's really clever in
other ways it's kind of a cop-out but
okay that's a whole nother video let's
talk about the movie in general the
movie is a send up to the classic
traditional Muppet films like The Muppet
movie or the great Muppet Caper Muppets
Take Manhattan the comedy is
straightforward but also strange simple
but with a lot of fourth wall jokes and
does a wonderful job at combining old
tricks with new tricks
classic humor with more modern humor but
that's only what makes it good what
makes it great are the emotional moments
this movie will make you feel sad that
you ever didn't look at the Muppets
there are so many song sequences and
moments of them just remembering the
good old days trying to figure out what
went wrong did they go south or did the
people just leave something like this
can get a little too heavy-handed but
they do it at just the right balance
every single time they have a song
trying to remember what happened
there's always another song that's very
upbeat and funny and again kind of like
the classic Muppet movies it's this kind
of clever directness that makes us
appreciate them so much more when they
get set up to sing the Rainbow
Connection it's a big tear-jerking scene
but the great thing about is that it
doesn't all rely on nostalgia there's
new stuff as well the new songs are
really great well one of them got
nominated for an Academy Award the new
techniques are great combining modern
day technology with well still the fact
that they're foam puppets and it's a
good combination they feel alive they
feel real even though we know they're
obviously just hands in foam but their
personalities are still so strong and so
likable that you just totally overlook
it and accept the madness is it flawless
not really there are a few nitpicks
for example there might be one too many
songs I remember one sequence that Chris
Cooper has I just remember scratching my
head saying what is the purpose of this
it's not especially funny it doesn't
further anything it's just kind of a
weird detour now don't get me wrong most
of them up in movies have weird detours
and yeah I kind of had a problem with
that too doesn't mean I don't have a
problem with it here also I get the idea
that they want Walter to look more human
but I don't know I think he's a very
unimaginative looking muppet they had
him around for a while but then when
they did the new Muppet Show they didn't
even include him in that he's by no
means a bad character each is kind of a
bland wide-eyed innocent he's needed for
the story and he's fine he's just not
that unique I also don't like this
telling at the end seems to rip off
Malcolm in the middle but hey
everybody's ripping off Malcolm the mill
nowadays but probably my biggest issue
is the ending and I'll do my best to
talk about without giving anything
way it looks like they're gonna go in
this one direction this direction that
isn't the 100% happy ending but it's
kind of the idea that we'll move on
we'll get past this we're still a family
we're still close we'll still do great
things I thought that was really
inspiring at a great angle but then at
the last minute literally during the
credits they just retconned the whole
thing and there's the 100% happy ending
they were just saying they weren't gonna
do that drives me nuts why do they have
to go that route they could have done
something really new and really
different but does it really ruin
anything I don't think so it's just sort
of an ending that I wish could have been
a little different the majority of the
movie hits all the marks it's supposed
to hit when you're supposed to laugh you
laugh when you're supposed to feel sad
you feel sad when you're supposed to
enjoy a really energetic song sequence
do you do when it's supposed to be slow
and dramatic it pays off when it's
supposed to be fast and energetic it's
really enjoyable I really like how the
writing and the direction and the jokes
are so similar to those first three
Muffet films yet it isn't just a
mindless retread they throw in new stuff
as well it's a really really good
balance from soothing song numbers to
pointless celebrity cameos to looking
right in the camera and making a joke to
the audience it's the Muppets and
they're right back on track if you love
them at their best you're definitely
gonna love them here